donc ce jour nous avons donc notre point
presse évidemment ce soir le président
assistera au dîner du crif
demain nicolas sarkozy se rendra à la
cérémonie d'hommage aux invalides à la
mémoire d'yves guéna à 15 heures
le président organise ici même dans le
cadre de la journée de la femme une
rencontre avec les nouvelles adhérentes
avec également l'équipe dirigeante les
femmes de l'équipe dirigeante afin
d'avoir un échange qui soit à la fois
conviviale mais également précis sur les
problématiques liées rencontrés par les
femmes
il y aura 18 heures notre bureau
politique mercredi nous vous invitons
tous à nous retrouver pour la
demi-journée de travail que nous
organisons sur la fonction publique et
la réforme de l'état avec un certain
nombre de propositions qui seront à ce
moment-là présenter et à midi le
discours de clôture de nicolas sarkozy
ce sera évidemment ici même au siège
et puis jeudi il y aura un déplacement
du président dans la fédération de
l'isère à l'invitation du député moyne
bressand pour la fête départementale de
ce département
et puis ce n'est pas cette semaine mais
nouveau l'annonçons le 18 mars le
président se rendra avec une délégation
parlementaire en côte d'ivoire à
l'invitation du président ouattara vous
donnera davantage de détails
quand le programme sera tu as fini voilà
je passe la parole à guillon merci de
deux points en ce qui me concerne non
seulement de répondre à vos questions
après que valerio révoquait d'autres
points d'abord un point d'actualité sur
la turquie
en ce jour où comme vous avez une
rencontre importante se tient au plan
européen
les républicains
nous formons le voeu que naturellement
le gouvernement turc prenne toute sa
part dans l'effort de maîtrise des flux
migratoires vers le continent européen
il ne peut pas y avoir à court terme de
solutions aux défis migratoires sans une
implication très forte des autorités
turques
au plan opérationnel toutefois de
manière assez solennel nous voulons
aujourd'hui mettre deux lignes rouges à
la négociation qui est engagée avec les
autorités turques
la première ligne rouge pour les
républicains c'est le refus absolu de
l'adhésion de la turquie à l'union
européenne
voici quelques semaines la commission
européenne a ouvert un nouveau chapitre
de négociation avec la turquie qui est
un chapitre monétaire qui est donc un
chapitre ayant comme perspective
l'adhésion nous appelons aujourd'hui
françois hollande a exprimé le veto de
la france à la poursuite de cette
discussion sur le chapitre moniteur de
l'adhésion la seconde ligne rouge que
nous souhaitons affirmer ce matin au
siège des républicains
c'est notre opposition à toute
perspective de libéralisation des visas
de court séjour de la turquie vers
l'union européenne
on peut envisager naturellement que des
facilités dans la délivrance de visas
soit accordée par exemple à des hommes
d'affaires les étudiants des facilités
ce qu'on appelle des visas de
circulation mais tous les visas de court
séjour libéralisait comme la commission
européenne en a fait la proposition d'un
amorcé la proposition ça c'est une
perspective qui ne nous va pas à ce
stade
dès lors qu'il n'ya pas de politique
commune de réduction de l'immigration
vers l'europe dès lors qu'il n'ya pas de
politique d'organisation de l'arrêt
action de l'immigration vers l'europe il
ne peut pas y avoir de libéralisation
des visas de court séjour de la turquie
vers l'europe voilà deux lignes rouges
qui nous semble très important de ne pas
perdre de vue
au moment où se tient à bruxelles
cet échange important avec les autorités
turques
seconde remarque sur un tout autre sujet
je voudrais au nom des républicains vous
rappeler que nous sommes bientôt à deux
ans de l'installation de manuel valls à
matignon que reste-t-il
deux ans après son installation à
matignon des ambitions réformatrices du
premier ministre question que nous
posons la hollande isation de manuel
valls le condamne à la communication
virtuelle et à l'inaction réel en
réalité level 6 mhz est un immobilisme
qui fait semblant de bouger après deux
ans à matignon le premier ministre en
effet fait face à cinq crises aiguës
asphyxie économique la pression fiscale
n'a jamais été aussi élevé le poids des
dépenses publiques et la
surréglementation bureaucratique pèsent
sur les entreprises asphyxie économique
deuxièmement colère sociale qui couve
parce que le chômage de masse alimente
le déclassement et le ressentiment
asphyxie économique colère sociale
troisièmement désordre territoriale qui
est parfois d'ailleurs sous-estimé ici à
paris mais qui est une réalité vécue je
le dis comme porte parole des
républicains et comme député rural de
bourgogne ruralité abandonnait
département conseils départementaux
maintenu en survie artificielle tout en
étant étrangler par une augmentation
totalement inconsidérée des dépenses
sociales imposées par l'état des
compétences toujours enchevêtrées au
plan territorial 0 clarifications et des
intercommunalités notamment dans les
territoires ruraux qui sont imposés par
les préfets donc un vrai désordre
territoriales qui suscite beaucoup de
ressentiment beaucoup d'exaspération qui
complique le montage des dossiers par
les élus locaux
quatrièmement chaos migratoires avec des
flux incontrôlé qui sont source de
désordre et cinquième manches faillite
sécuritaire avec une délinquance
désormais installé protégé par
l'impunité pénale et c5 crise s'y ajoute
désormais un blocage politique car la
majorité on le voit bien est aussi
fébrile que fragile alors il ya deux ans
dans son discours de politique générale
que j'ai relu ce matin manuel valls
s'était référée à pierre mendès france
et à son exigence de vérité
nous lui disons aujourd'hui manuel valls
que l'exigence et de ne plus faire
semblant de gouverner et donc au nom des
républicains
j'appelle le premier ministre à venir
devant l'assemblée nationale présenté un
nouveau discours de politique générale
pour exposer sa feuille de route
expliqué quels sont les textes dont le
parlement sera saisi dans les mois à
venir exposer ses choix et vérifier si
la majorité a encore la majorité en
engageant sa responsabilité sur un
discours de politique générale globale
encore une fois exposant ses priorités
son calendrier sa volonté
voilà
au point que je voulais évoquer j'en un
troisième qui est un peu plus technique
je veux signaler que ça concerne les
élus locaux vient l'assemblée nationale
mercredi une proposition de loi qui
concerne les élus locaux et l'ensemble
des députés républicains présentes à
cette occasion un amendement que je
défendrai comme orateur du groupe pour
rétablir une liberté
j'explique en mars 2015 ya une loi qui a
été votée c'est pas la loi note c'est
notre homme en mars 2015 et une loi qui
a été voté qui oblige
en réalité les maires des communes de
moins de 1000 habitants à augmenter
leurs indemnités d'une bizarrerie ça a
été voté par la majorité socialiste en
mars 2015
ça suscite dans tous les territoires
beaucoup d'interrogations
parce que les maires ruraux souhaite
pouvoir faire délibérer leurs conseils
municipaux ils souhaitent pas
nécessairement avoir une augmentation
des indemnités
bien souvent ils ont des budgets très
contraint il préférait affecter ce
surcroît d'indemnités à un projet local
beaucoup de maires ont saisi les
parlementaires républicains et donc nous
prenons deux initiatives au sénat
sénateur jean baptiste lemoyne a fait
cosigné par de très nombreux sénateurs
une proposition de loi pour redonner
cette liberté aux moeurs et
parallèlement à l'assemblée nationale je
présenterai mercredi un amendement
cosigné par tout le groupe républicain
pour redonner cette liberté au maire
l'association des maires ruraux que
préside monsieur barberio indiqué qu'ils
soutenaient cette initiative et je
comprends aussi que l'association des
maires de france y est favorable
je vous le signale parce que c'est un
sujet qui peut être vu de paris n'est
pas important mais qui a vraiment son
importance on peut pas comprendre au
moment où nos concitoyens doivent se
serrer la ceinture au moment où les
budgets locaux sont extrêmement
contraint par une baisse drastique des
dotations imposé par le goût
en nommant on peut pas comprendre que
cette espèce de bizarreries législatives
imposé par les socialistes en 2015 est
vraiment des effets pervers et donc on
appelle madame grelier la nouvelle
secrétaire d'état chargé des
collectivités monsieur bah il est le
ministre chargé des collectivités
regardez cet amendement de bon sens avec
beaucoup d'attention et à l'adopter
dès mercredi au moment où je vous le
rappelle les communes votent leur budget
merci merci merci guillaume pour
bêtement en exergue ce que guillaume
avancé sur le val cisme immobile
souhaitons revenir sur ce qui va se
passer ce mercredi avec une grève
annoncée d'ampleur par rapport à la loi
sur le travail qui est présenté par
madame elle comme rri soyons clair sur
ses principes
cette loi a du bon le problème c'est
qu'elle arrive à la fin d'un quinquennat
et qu'elle arrive dans des conditions
qui sont plus que complexe
alors elle est mal engagée en plus ça à
plusieurs titres parce que pour
l'anecdote mais l'anecdote révèle
l'amateurisme du gouvernement monsieur
valls quand il en parle dans le jdd ce
week-end il semble lui même ne pas très
bien connaître les chiffres du chômage
puisqu'ils indiquent qu'un quart des
jeunes sont au chômage et que donc il
faut absolument que ces jeunes puissent
bénéficier de ce dispositif pour pouvoir
en sortir
heureusement y'a pas un quart des jeunes
dans notre pays qui sont au chômage mais
un septième beaucoup soit un peu moins
de 15%
mais il faut aussi raison garder alors
soit c'est vraiment une méconnaissance
des chiffres soit c'est une volonté de
grossir un effectif je ne le pense pas
mais on voit aussi que cet élément
d'amateurisme qui est jumelée avec la
présentation des chiffres du chômage sur
le mois dernier où malheureusement on
voit quand même que il n'ya plus que de
l'imprécision dans la façon dont on
prend la connaissance de ces chiffres
montrent que le gouvernement après en
mal ce texte et ses enjeux et
aujourd'hui que voyons-nous un texte qui
va être vu à la moulinette du parti
socialiste demain puisque le parti
socialiste doit dans ses fédérations
indiquaient ce qu'il veut conserver ou
pas de ce texte
deux choses l'une où ce texte est
essentiel pour l'avenir notre pays et il
y a un président de la république un
premier ministre qui ne jouent pas le
l'immobilisme et il y à des actions ou
alors ce n'est jamais qu'un petit
règlement hollandais habituel de
sections socialistes et à ce moment là
pourquoi le présenter il faut
effectivement la matière savoir ce qu'on
veut il va être passée à la moulinette
des fédérations socialistes il va être
passée à la moulinette des syndicats que
va-t-il en restait encore une fois
principe bon texte qui va arriver dans
un état avancé de faim est une
application qui est plus qu'hypothétique
sur ce texte
que retient que retenons nous nous les
répliques un de ceux là
encore une fois tout cela est le
résultat des mensonges de la campagne de
françois hollande françois hollande n'a
pas dit qu'il ferait ce texte pendant sa
campagne il n'a pas indiqué qui réforme
elle aurait le droit du travail et donc
l'ensemble des français et plus
particulièrement son électorat puisqu'on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui le coeur de
l'opposition à ce texte c'est son
électorat bien se sent trahie floués et
voit en ce président évidemment celui
qui n'a pas respecté ses engagements et
ça nous amène effectivement à cette
résolution majeur il faut tout dire
avant pour tout faire après et on voit à
quel point aujourd'hui françois hollande
face à ses propres mensonges et bien se
prend la porte du syndicalisme du parti
socialiste et de ses électeurs en plein
visage
nous terminerons avant de répondre à vos
questions qui vous souhaitez avec la
journée de la femme qui a lieu demain
alors au delà effectivement des
manifestations qui vont avoir lieu qui
sont importantes
nous souhaitons nous interpeller le
gouvernement et le président de la
république par rapport à un certain
nombre de promesses qui ont été faites
aux femmes et pour revenir sur la
thématique du chômage vous savez très
bien que aujourd'hui les femmes sont les
premières victimes du chômage avec
notamment les contrats précaires subi et
un taux de chômage bien supérieure dans
le cadre de l'activité à celui qui
rencontrait par les hommes et vous savez
que pour que une femme puisse avoir une
activité ou une formation pleinement
exercées il lui faut avoir un mode de
garde qui lui permettent effectivement
quand elle a des enfants quand avait
choisi d'avoir des enfants et bien
l'exercer à la fois son activité
professionnelle de façon épanouissante
et son rôle de maman de façon
épanouissant dans ce cadre là une
promesse qui étaient importantes du
candidat hollande était la création de
cent mille places de crèche avec
notamment dans le cadre du périscolaire
la création de 75 mille places pour
permettre un vous savez le périscolaire
c'est à dire au delà des heures normales
de scolarisation est bien de garder les
enfants
aujourd'hui non seulement on n'est pas
évidemment on sent les deux places et on
a à peine à dix mille places degrés on
voit bien que les fed annonce encore une
fois n'est pas au bout de la réalisation
est aussi on jumelle cette difficulté à
la baisse du quotient familial à la
baisse des allocations familiales
on voit bien que les femmes qui sont on
peut le regretter mais néanmoins celle
qui garde les enfants et qui ont cette
responsabilité infiné et bien sont
impactés encore une fois par des
difficultés qui ont été mises en place
par le gouvernement parce que ce sont
elles qui devront choisir de façon très
majoritaire de renoncer à travailler et
les décisions qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement est bien loin de libérer
les femmes
aujourd'hui les entravent un peu plus
un peu plus et ne leur permettent pas de
sortir à la fois de la précarité de
reprendre une formation est de trouver
un emploi il nous semble qu'en la
matière l'objectif n'a pas été atteint
et il est importante que au delà de
quelques petites photos dans l qui sont
somme toute assez intéressante à voir
il y est une réalité d'exercice est bien
de cette volonté de libérer les femmes
et d accompagner dans leur volonté
travaillait nous considérons nous sommes
loin de la coupe aux lèvres à boston sur
la loue elle conneries françois hollande
a réussi a réussi pardon à ressusciter
georges marchais fait parce que en
réalité de martine aubry jusqu'à florian
philippot vous avez une espèce de ligne
presque néo communistes qui est en train
de s'exprimer c'est à dire c'est la lie
de tous ceux qui ne veulent rien changer
jamais sur rien c'est intéressant de
voir cela c'est ce président socialiste
qui avait été élu avec le soutien de
jean luc mélenchon qui in fine est
réussi à ressusciter un courant néo
communistes dans l'opinion publique
singularité française